let's bring in Reggie Allah wishes
Miller the Hall of Famer NBA on TNT
analyst reg gets the call Thursday night
the Lakers in the Cavaliers 8:00 Eastern
on TNT how about that matchup reg I'm
excited about that because you've got
the red-hot Cleveland Cavaliers
obviously the frontrunner in my opinion
for the MVP in the Bron James particular
in him in his 15th season and a fun team
to watch your favorite team the Los
Angeles Lakers you love watching this
young talent evolve they do play hard I
like their style of play they're gonna
have their ups and downs but the product
is much better than it's been the last
couple of years for the Lakers Brandon
Ingram has made a there's something
that's different with him this year
as opposed to previous you know two
previous years but what has changed with
Brandon Ingram
I think his confidence truly has dropped
gone through the roof and if you look
over the last three to four weeks Luke
Walton has done a great job of basically
just putting the ball in his hands and
letting him be the go-to guy and the
game winner in Philly the coming out
game versus Kevin Durant and the
Warriors even though they lost the game
at Staples to go toe-to-toe with the
Finals MVP it was a confidence booster
for Ingram and you see each and every
game him getting the opportunity to be
the go-to player on this young team and
he's evolving into that yeah he's fun to
watch and you see that there's this
improvement III didn't know if he would
grow into that body
not that Durant has grown into his and
and maybe he he can kind of look at
Durant and modeled his game after him
but I've seen market improvement and by
all accounts people with the Lakers say
he's first there and last to leave that
he's putting in the effort and it's
certainly showing so it'll be Lakers
Cavaliers coming up at 8:00 Eastern on
Thursday night on TNT have you seen
enough with the Thunder do you have an
opinion
we talked about this the first the first
two weeks of the season you and I that I
wasn't going to get too high or too low
on teams I
the hot starts or teens that were
struggling I usually like to give all
teams until January first is it head
scratching but after 2016 this team is
12 and 14 absolutely
lack of ball movement and between the
big three of the Thunder Westbrook
George melon Carmelo all three need to
have the basketball D to be successful
there's no one that's making anyone else
better so it's certainly been head
scratching but they've got in my opinion
before I really start to judge the team
two to three more weeks because of their
playing like this and hovering around
500 come January 1st I know you've seen
the movie Titanic right yes I am you
remember when the band continued to play
yes yeah cue the music or the Thunder
okay because this ship might be thinking
but look this is also a team that can go
on to win eight or ten straight games
because they have that type of talent
but something is not right offensively
for this team and I look at the players
you know Paul George leaves Indiana in
his spot Victor Oladipo is thriving you
know
Carmelo he Exodus the New York Knicks
the unicorn is thriving so I don't know
something else could be playing into
this not could you see a scenario where
the Thunder realized Paul George is not
going to stay and why would you stay and
you trade him I don't think they would
trade them they certainly knew this
could potentially be a rental and I
think they did this which I think Sam
Presti was a great move for your fan
base because you're showing them the
year all in you go out and get a top 15
talent like Paul George the team with
you know the reigning MVP and then you
bring in Carmelo Anthony who is a Hall
of Fame talent and you show your fan
base hey we want to go after it this
year we don't know what's going to
happen come summer
and free agency but we're going after it
this year and the expectations were so
high it takes time for chemistry to form
but again this team on paper and let's
throw in Steven Adams Steven Adams is a
really he's not a great center but he's
a very good capable sinner so they have
four pieces that they certainly should
not be 12 and 14 at this point Chuck a
new Reggie Miller NBA on TNT I know you
said LeBron for MVP I'm watching Harden
and it's a it's no I mean reg I go back
and forth I go back and forth you're
right you're right he sort of decides
what he wants to do each had 14 assists
in the what first quarter first half
last night I mean crazy crazy you're not
wrong if you're picking James Harden for
nvv right am i right you said I'm not
wrong but am i right you're not wrong
it's all about a personal preference
I just think LeBron James after the
start they had and then the run they
went on to win 12 or 13 in a row and the
injuries Derrick Rose going m.i.a
there has been no IT I think there's
better talent on Houston and I know
Chris Paul was out you know the first
two or three weeks but when he came back
they've gone and I shred I just think
LeBron James and what he has done and I
take into account both sides of the
court I do and I mean I understand that
harden is great but I got to take in
both sides of the floor in LeBron James
he just does it for me how does how do
you explain LeBron shooting from three
the success he's had this year where
he's shooting better than Steph Curry is
injured all not all a year but I mean
injury two is their fingers and then
obviously he's out now because of the
ankle injury so that hasn't been hole
for LeBron how about at 15th year into
in the league working on something
that's probably not been his strong suit
his shooting so time in the lab really
but after 15 years all of his
becomes dangerous where people now say
do you want to be in the three-point
shooting contest ah no no no no don't
get ahead of yourself LeBron you're
shooting great don't ask don't don't
pull a Michael and say you want to be in
the shooting contest which they did
grant Michael to shoot in the
three-point competition one year I think
he finished last that year cuz I was in
it with Larry FEC it was myself
Larry obviously Michael it might have
been Hodges Mark Price was Dale Ellis in
there I don't think he I think he may
have finished last but that's not the
one that bird said hey no no no years
later no years later yes was years later
because he wouldn't have said that to
you
woody Larry yeah would he have walked in
and said which one are you playing for
second okay but who was cockier in
something like that Jordan er bird bird
really people want to go to sleep on
Larry Bird's trash talking Larry Joe
Bird was a supreme southern drawl trash
talker and that's what made it hilarious
was at Indiana drawl which one of yous
playing for second I love it okay did
you ever play overseas exhibition games
I you know I saw where the ball boys are
playing in Lithuania I don't know if you
have any experience any stories that you
played over there with the Pacers or
traveling teams aside from the Olympics
yes our Pacers team went to Spain and we
went to Germany to kind of spread the
stoke of NBA basketball it's different
but this was in the infancy stage of
world basketballs though the talent
level wasn't there they were just
excited to have NBA product over there
and watch us perform the game has grown
obviously internationally so
this is gonna be curious this is a huge
call for papa ball and these younger
ball brothers to go over you know to
Russia in play so it's different
my question is who's gonna stay over
there with them they've got to have some
type of yeah
parental is there gonna be mama ball is
Papa balls gonna be going back and forth
because you certainly sir today younger
one you cannot have him over there by
himself and you certainly don't want the
older ball like being the parent over
there we we all know what happened the
last time there was no parental
supervision for jello ball but LAN jello
is what 19 and lamelle Oh is 16 but to
be playing against these grown men over
there I don't know if it's gonna how
much does it help your game do you think
playing against guys like that in an
atmosphere like that and you're away
from home it always helps playing
against older guys I mean you're gonna
get stronger you're gonna learn the game
it depends on how much they play you
know and according to Lavar the reason
why you probably picked this team is he
needed his two sons we're gonna get a
lot of runs but everything I've been
reading about this coach from this team
she's a lot like levar ball so we'll see
how that dynamic works out but we'll see
here's the thing they've got to get on
the court they got to play this is all
this is almost kind of possibly like
Paul George they're raiding the balls
for the year because they just want to
get back and hopefully get drafted which
will not happen they'll probably get
drafted but I just don't see either one
of them playing in the NBA I just don't
read you've got the Cavs with LeBron dis
LeBron say hello to you prior to the
game how does that what happened uh he
does know but fist bump or no wave
that's about it no like well you think
what no no no no I just curious how it
works when you go to that you know
you're a hall-of-famer you one of the
greatest shooters in the history of the
game you know I tap everyone i def
everyone and i say hello to everyone
no that's not to say everyone says hello
back but I tried to hello to everyone
okay all right and then you'll you'll
tap out the DAP up the Lakers as well
I'll duck out Lonzo and Kyle Kuzma and
Ingram and of course Luke Walton oh cool
I love as a head coach okay all right
both safe travels to Cleveland there and
have some fun as only you can reg be it
are you are yeah I think about a jingle
bell Jingle Bell Rock are the kids all
excited with Christmas yeah no one but
one thing that is driving me crazy I did
not grow up with this I don't know maybe
you grew up with this
what is Elf on the Shelf we're doing
this in our household and it is driving
me absolutely crazy and moving this elf
every day I can't talk about it because
there could be kids listening okay I
can't do I love it put Muggsy Bogues up
there could be your elf on the shelf
maybe spiderweb I hope on the Shelf
there Price Elf on the Shelf here too
hey reg safe travels Thank You bud talk
to you soon thank you my friend
that's a Reggie Allah wishes Miller jr.
the third for more Dan Patrick show to
the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]